CONTRACTED THE VIRUS.
NOW BACK TO HANNITY.
>> EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED A PEACE DEAL BETWEEN
BAHRAIN AND ISRAEL WHICH IS
ANOTHER MASSIVE HUGE STEP
TOWARDS MIDDLE EAST PEACE.
SO COMMIT THE MOB, THE MEDIA
GIVE THIS MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENT
THE CREDIT IT DESERVES?
THEY DIDN’T MENTION THE FIRST
PEACE DEAL WITH THE UAE, I DOUBT
THEY WILL DO IT HERE.
YESTERDAY, NEW DOCUMENTS
RELEASED BY THE DOJ SHOWING THAT
MULTIPLE MEMBERS OF THE TEAM,
ACTUALLY WIPED THEIR PHONES
CLEAN BEFORE TURNING THEM OVER
TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
TODAY REPUBLICANS ARE RIGHTLY
DEMANDING ANSWERS AND SUGGESTING
THIS COULD AMOUNT TO
ANTICIPATORY OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE FROM THE
MOB AND THE MEDIA?
IMAGINE IF DONALD TRUMP DID IT.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE GET
PROSECUTED BY THE MOLAR, MOB FOR
PROCESS CRIMES, INCLUDING
OBSTRUCTION AND NOT HANDING OVER
E-MAILS, AND LYING TO CONGRESS,
DIDN’T WAIT?
COULD GET YES WE DID.
NOW WE LEARN WHAT HIS TEAM WAS
DOING.
SEVERAL DOZEN, SEVERAL DOZEN
DEVICES WERE TURNED DAMAGED,
WIPED CLEAN, SOME OF THEM
INTENTIONALLY SO.
ONE OF THOSE DEVICES WAS ANDREW
WISEMAN.
>> TO WEAR HIS BREATH.
>> HAD PROSECUTORIAL OVERREACH.
TO AMONG THESE DEFENDERS, MILLER
AS SAYING WE WILL PROSECUTE VIEW
, SEVERAL DOZENS OF US ARE
ENGAGING IN THE SAME KIND OF
CONSTRUCTION.
>> IT JUST SHOWS THE DEPTH AT
WHICH THIS HAS GOTTEN OUT OF
CONTROL BECAUSE WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THEY WERE WARNED NUMEROUS
TIMES, EVEN BEFORE THE FIRST
PFIZER WARRANT WAS ISSUED COMMIT
WE KNOW THAT THEY WERE WARNED BY
THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HAS AN AGENDA
, HILLARY PAID FOR IT AND
IT’S NOT VERIFIED.
THEY SIGNED IT ANYWAY.
WHEN THEY GOT TO THE SUB SOURCE,
THE SOURCE BEHIND THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT HILLARY
PAID FOR, THEN THEY FOUND OUT IN
JANUARY OF 2017 THE SUB SOURCE
SAID THIS IS ALL TALK.
IT’S NOT TRUE.
NOW WE KNOW IT WAS DEBUNKED SO
IT WAS NEVER VERIFIABLE SO WHICH
MEANS WE NEVER SHOULD’VE HAD AN
INVESTIGATION PERIOD.
I DON’T HEAR FROM YOUR FRIENDS
IN THAT PRESS ROOM WITH YOU
REGULARLY, HAMMERING YOU WITH
QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE ISSUES.
WHY?
>> THEY DON’T CARE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I BEEN ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT VERY LEGITIMATE
THINGS LIKE MICHAEL FLYNN, THE
INJUSTICE DONE TO HIM.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, THAT
OVAL OFFICE MEETING DURING MY
TENURE WE FOUND OUT SUSAN RICE
ON THE WAY OUT THE DOOR WRITES
THIS E-MAIL INSCRIBING AND
MEETING FROM DAYS PRIOR, WEEKS
PRIOR, ACTUALLY THAT SAYS OBAMA
DID EVERYTHING BY THE BOOK.
THIS WAS A VERY CURIOUS E-MAIL
COMMIT NOT ASKED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY DON’T CARE
AND THERE ARE TWO TIERS OF
JUSTICE IN THE COUNTRY 14
MUELLER AND HILLARY CLINTON
PAIRED.
>> THE PRESIDENT DISCUSSED THIS
YESTERDAY, THE PRESIDENT LAYS IT
OUT AND COMMIT DO YOU GET ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ABUSE OF
POWER, AND CORRUPTION OF THEM,
DO YOU GET ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THEM?
>> ZERO.
LITERALLY ZERO FROM THE REPORTER
SITTING THERE IN THE CHAIRS IN
THE BRIEFING ROOM, NONE.
I EVEN ACQUIRED YOU HOW MANY OF
YOU HAVE REACHED OUT TO OBAMA’S
OFFICE HIS REPRESENTATIVES TO
ASK THEM QUESTIONS.
NOT A SINGLE HAND WENT UP
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY DON’T CARE.
>> EVERY SINGLE DAY I WATCH THE
MEDIA, FOR EXAMPLE I WATCH THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT ACTED ON TEN DAYS
AFTER THE FIRSTLY IDENTIFIED
CASE OF CORONAVIRUS, THAT WAS
JANUARY 21ST.
AT THE TRAVEL BAN WENT INTO
EFFECT ON JANUARY 31ST.
JOE BIDEN ON FEBRUARY 1ST SAID
IT WAS HYSTERICAL AND FEAR
MONGERING.
HE SAID IT ALL THROUGHOUT THE
MONTH OF JANUARY COME AT THE
MONTH OF FEBRUARY, AND DEEP INTO
MARCH.
NOW, HE IS SAYING OH NO, WE
SUPPORTED THE TRAVEL BAN AT THE
TIME.
>> IT’S AMAZING.
HE DIDN’T SUPPORT THE CHINA
TRAVEL BAN, THEY DIDN’T SUPPORT
THE EUROPEAN TRAVEL BAN PAIRED
HIS ADVISERS SAYING IT WOULD
TURN INTO SERIOUS PANDEMIC AND
NOTING HIS SAME ADVISOR IS THE
ONE THAT SAID WE BARELY SURVIVED
IT WAS NEURAL FORTUITY THAT THE
SWINE FLU WAS NOT ONE OF THE
MASS CASUALTY EVENT OF OUR TIME.
>> I DON’T THINK YOU GET PAID
ENOUGH, I COULD NOT DO YOUR JOB
AT.
IT’S JOB IMPOSSIBLE.